so think about it for longest time
people are working out of an office
everything's going good in and all of a
sudden boom unless if you're not working
in an essential business go home what do
you mean go home go work from home I
fired no no go work from home but but
wait a minute
I've always worked out of a building but
go work from home so then the person
doesn't know what it's like to work from
home the boss doesn't know how to hold
people accountable that's working from
home then the boss's boss doesn't know
how to hold a boss and accountable to
get their employees to do the work to
work from home everybody's confused so
today we're going to talk about how to
properly work from home so look this
working remotely is not a challenge it's
been going on for a long time it's not
like it's a new thing the biggest
challenge that today employers are
having with employees is the fact that
employers are asking w-2 people to work
from home and employers don't
necessarily trust that employees know
how to deliver on their job and the
responsibilities they have because
they've always been working out of an
office and when you work from home
freelancers have been doing it for a
while they know the distractions they
know when you're working from home you
got news you've got kids that are
running around and there's nothing more
distracting and if you got young kids
you're trying to do your work and your
kids are there your wife is there your
boyfriend your girlfriend your husband
you got sex as the distraction beds as a
distraction refrigerator as a
distraction the news as a distraction
movies as a distraction Netflix as a
distraction all of that is right there
available to you but if somebody's been
a freelancer and if I hire freelancers I
have 14,000 plus salespeople licensed
agents nationwide but I have a lot of
freelancers that work to work progenies
technology back-end who work with me
freelance because we pay him per project
so I don't sit there and say am i paying
this guy too much no because it's
project basis he makes a adjustment on a
technology I owe you $3,000 you do this
I owe you $18,000 you fill fill this we
owe you this much I hired 17 project
guys here's how much I owe you but it's
very honest relationship and simple the
challenges here w-2 folks all of a
sudden pandemic
Crona virus happens everybody's got to
go war quarantine April 30 at all this
stuff now they got to work from home but
I still have to pay you a salary and
your bonuses that's the problem the
employer says is this w2 person gonna
really work properly or they're gonna
take advantage of me and that's where
you see friction so the employee you
know some of the people are like I have
friends that are saying oh my gosh this
is so cool man my company so great I'm
working from home and they don't even
bother me and they don't do any of this
stuff let me put it to you this way when
you're working from home there's pros
and cons pros you are working from home
the con is what you're not really around
to have one company's loyalty and you're
under more scrutiny if you don't fulfill
your commitments with your job because
it's a it's a very nice privilege to
have to be working from home as a w-2
person and still get paid the salary so
if you abuse it this much you used to be
able to use it this much at work but if
you abused it this much working from
home you're probably gonna get fired by
the employer because employer doesn't
want to waste money paying you the
salary that they have so that's that
part that's the friction that's taking
place now some companies are using zoom
go to webinar we are going away from
GoToWebinar we have too many challenges
with these guys their server doesn't
seem to be able to handle it zoom is
doing a pretty good job we did a
GoToWebinar yesterday with 3,000 people
we prepared them they knew what's coming
up and it's still flop static so they
lost a big customer like ours that we've
spent a lot of money and our guys use a
lot of money using them but zoom slim
pretty good they're still having some
issues but not at the level GoToWebinar
but you'll see a lot of people that are
using their platforms and they're seeing
all the employees what do you call it
screens and some of the bosses are
looking at it or leader of a department
or manager to kind of see and everybody
can let me see your share let me see
this so it's visual and that's making it
comfortable for people to work together
because everyone's seen that somebody is
working so you got a leader and she's
watching everybody in that department
right so now let's look at remotely how
this works for people that are w2 going
to work remotely during the time like
this number one whatever schedule you
got stick your schedule no matter what
it is stick to the schedule that ship if
it's 8 o'clock
don't be late to your desk or whatever
your workplace is that go don't show up
at 808 or a tone out or be casual about
it just treat it as if it's your work
number
to dress for work if you wear a suit
wear a suit if you dress sharp dress
sharp but if you put on a nice polo put
on a nice polo don't go in with a tee
shirt because you're you're not gonna
treat something classy with the best
effort if you're not dressed up the same
way you traditionally dress up when you
go to work dress sharp as if you're
going to work number three leave your
house and come back to the house to go
to work meaning if you're working from
home leave you if you're working at 8
o'clock leave your house for 15 minutes
go walk around and then come into your
house at 7:59 and go straight to your
office as if you're going to work I
don't know if that make sense
psychologically I'm leaving I'm coming
back in I'm going to work it makes me
feel like I disconnect it I come back to
going to my work number 4 internet
connection is one of the biggest
challenges you're seeing people having
with their employers and employers the
home office doesn't have solid internet
connection and if you don't have solid
internet connection one the first things
you got to do is make sure you have a
solid internet connection
because if you don't deliver on your
promises then you get fired and you the
reason why you got fired is because you
didn't have good internet connection
that's on you to make sure you prevent
that from happening so make sure your
bandwidth is strong number five set
standard and expectation with whoever
lives with you got a roommate let them
know I'm work and don't bother me hey
you want to play video games and you're
23 years old you got a roommate wants to
play Madden because that guy's fired and
you're not fired you're trying to keep
your job he's fired you still got a job
you're merry tell your wife you want me
to keep bringing money and maybe you got
let me get to work hey you tell your
husband you got your kids manage
expectation with the kids because a lot
of times right now it's what kids are
not at school they're at home so it's
even more complicated than ever before
you need help to make it work number six
build a workplace if there's a place
that you have set it up as if it's your
workplace make you feel like your office
you know create the exact type of
environment that you have whatever you
need if you got a you know your computer
your laptop that whatever screens you
use make it seem like just like it's
your workplace and it's dedicated don't
do it on the bed or you know on the
couch and any that stuff you're not
gonna be as effective you don't wanna be
sitting down like that the way you sit
when you're in the moment while you
working get yourself an accountant that
kind of a setting 7 over communicate
over communicate up over communicate
side over can make it to the people
you're reporting or
communicate to customers over
communicate and document everything that
everybody know that you're not one of
those people that's abusing this
privilege of working from home because
you're coming above and above and beyond
everybody else you're working you're not
like oh my gosh this is so awesome I'm
working from home no I'm taking this
thing seriously if you trust me for me
to work from home I'm gonna come to
prove to you guys that I can do this
number eight don't tell friends that
you're home working from home and your
friends can just come over hey how you
doing can I see you no no what are you
doing coming over I'm working yeah but
you know you're working from home you
know you can kind of just let's have a
lunch where I can't I'm working from
home leave I got to work what are you
talking about this I'm trying to keep my
job you're fired I'm not fired I still
have a job let me keep my job I'll call
you at six o'clock whatever that's
whatever man I'm trying to get my job
you go home you stay committed to your
job that's paying your bills number now
protect confidential info some of you
guys are working in industries that you
have access to socials or you have
access to data and all that stuff make
sure your line that you're using your
internet bandwidth you're using is also
protected because that's a form of
liability and bother if you're an
employer also want to make sure your
employees are using the kind of
protection that the information is not
being leaked out to other people because
that's that's the kind of information
and you need to make sure you protect
and last but not least deliver on
everything your employer your boss so
your supervisor your manager is asking
you and don't just hit the deadline
deliver incredible product before the
deadline for them to say one thing I
know about Bobby if we say Friday at 3
o'clock he's gonna get it to us Friday
by 1 o'clock and it's flawless we have
people that worked from home
and we gave them a deadline and deliver
the terrible product unfortunately we
had to let him go because it's showing
you cannot show discipline of working
from home this happened in the past and
when this took place look if we're
giving you the opportunity and your
quality of work was better when you were
working out of an office you're saying
you want to work from home no problem
we'll let you work from home but the
quality drop tremendously and you didn't
hit your deadline which you're telling
us is you cannot stay focused at the
house we don't know what you're doing we
don't have cameras all over the place
we just know you can't keep your
commitment but if you do that
conversation doesn't come up and guess
what's built once Trust is built nobody
worries about this
don't worry about this when there's no
trust because delivery of war quality is
going lower and lower and lower now I
made this video specifically this way
because many employers are linked and
were asking me telling me Pat can you
make a video like that so I can share
with my employees for them to know how
we're feeling of what we're feeling I
said yes of course but I've also been
asked to make videos like this by
employees saying can I share this one my
boss for them to see cuz I'm doing my
part because if you're an employee
that's doing this part you'll share this
video with your boss to say you can
count on me and if you're an employer
and you're worried about some of your
gas you'll share this with them to say
this is pretty much what we're going
through this may not be a bad video for
you to watch with your teammates so
having said that again
conflicts are gonna happen a lot at the
office as well when you're working this
way you need to figure out how to manage
conflicts I did a video I think a year
year and a half ago titled 8 keys on
conflict revolutionary revolutions if
you've never watched this on how to
resolve conflicts click on a link over
here watch this video as well it's
detailed it's stories it's examples of
what I've done over the years I can
hopefully help you out as well during
your time like this and if you'd like to
get the since entire infographic sent
over to you text us 3 1 0 3 4 0 1 1 3 2
3 1 0 3 4 0 1 1 3 2 text conflict 2 3 1
0 3 4 0 1 1 3 2 again conflict - the
number here will send you the
infographic for you to see maybe you can
even share with your employees if you
like and if you around the world you're
not in the States
click on a link below subscribe to the
newsletter will send you the infographic
is 1 and if you haven't subscribed to
the channel please do so thanks for
watching everybody take care bye bye
you
[Music]